gray food nurtures your body and also
your soul
my name is Amelia Moran secre I am
president and founder of saving yards in
the Napa Valley if I was missing for
solid on the Thanksgiving table I would
be missing a glimpse of my village and
the smell and aroma of my grandmother's
kitchen but solely because it's made
with hominy corn it's native to Mexico
I make my pasola recipe from my state of
jalisco pourcel is special to me because
I held my grandmother prepare it for the
first time when I was around maybe two
it takes other members of the family to
help prepare it when I make it I can
have my daughter or my son's help me
chop all the garnishments like the
cabbage the radishes cilantro when I
Serpas Solea Thanksgiving and I see my
family and my friends I'm reminded of my
childhood and I am so delighted to be
able to enjoy it here in my adopted
country as well
you